road is long but well worth traveling so
time for another of my little
self-indulgence is I'm gonna talk about
why it's awesome and I'm gonna stick to
video games this time but I am also
going to depart from the last couple of
video games I've talked about for why
it's awesome because those were 16-bit
games from the Super Nintendo and most
the time I talked about video games on
why it's awesome that's what they're
gonna be that was my heyday as a gamer
and those are most those are most of my
favorite games and I and I've mentioned
before I don't have a current gen gaming
system I have a ps3 that's as current as
I get I don't plan to get a current gen
gaming system and I don't have a
computer that could support modern names
either so I'm not up to date with games
but there is a game that I played on the
ps3 and I want to talk about cuz it was
an amazing experience to play through
and that was journey I had heard a lot
of great things about journey but I
hadn't like really dug into a ton of the
details about it I knew it was like kind
of sort of multiplayer not really like I
knew that I knew that it was very
minimalistic in its storytelling that
was kind of it though so I popped it in
I and I sat down the plate thinking that
I would do what I tend to do with a lot
of video games especially these days is
I'll play for a little bit and get a
sense of you know how much time I'm
prepared to devote to this because my
time to play video games these days is
really sporadic which which makes
finishing games really hard because
sometimes I can find myself without the
time to plug back into them for weeks
and then I'm like I've lost the rhythm
so I thought I was just gonna sit down
and just get a feel for the thing
two and a half hours later when I
finished it I'm just sitting there in a
trance and if you've never played
Journey two and a half hour sounds a
really short like what's the point it's
the perfect length for what the game is
and what the game is doing because it's
not it's not a particularly challenging
game I'm not going to say it's challenge
free but it's it's not it's not
excessively difficult to get through I
got through without dying I got thrown
my first playthrough and then I I do
believe that is the intention of the
game that you pop it in you play it all
the way through continuously and you
have a two to three hour continuous
experience and I did and it was amazing
so what is so good about this well let's
start with the look it is a wonderfully
visually realized world and actually
there was a point I don't know if it's
about half way in or yeah I'm gonna say
about half way in where there's a sequel
because you start at you start out in a
desert and there's just a mountain in
the distance go up that mountain the
game and the game doesn't even really
tell you that it's like well there's
nowhere else to go off we go on a
journey up the mountain and you start on
a very desert II environment and there's
a point where you start to go through
some ruins and your character is kind of
sliding down this thing and the camera
rotates so it's not behind you anymore
now it's to the side so you're in
silhouette and the sun is shining
through and it's glistening off the sand
and it seriously took my breath away and
it's not just because of how gorgeous
the visual is is because of the seamless
transition to it this was not a cutscene
I wasn't extracted from gameplay in
order to get this it was perfectly
integrated moment into the organic
gaming that was already going on and it
it left me speechless it was gorgeous
and the game as a whole is gorgeous it
it is not just you know this sort of
bright sandy thing you get someone you
get
miss Furyk foreboding areas the the tail
end of it the very ending stretch is so
tense
large part to the visual presentation of
it there is a story or rather there's a
back story that you can learn and I do
think I'm more or less got it but that
wasn't what I was invested in I wasn't
invested in the why things are like this
now I was really invested in getting my
character my avatar just this little
voiceless character that you can just
emot-- like a single note and a long
scarf up this mountain I got really
invested in that despite the fact that
it's not really character the your
avatar is not really characterized at
all like I shouldn't get that invested
but I was I was seriously invested and I
and I was afraid for him this is it this
is there there are a couple points where
there are enemies yeah and you can't
fight them you can't fight these things
you need to avoid them at all cost and I
was scared of these things because I I
just I didn't I didn't want the journey
damn I sure as heck didn't wanted to end
like that at the hands of these things
and so you know just trying to avoid
them was so tense because I was so
wrapped up on it and there's a point
where you get out of sort of the
darkened areas and your your character
is practically flying and there's these
gorgeous waterfalls and this wonderful
moment of triumph and it's not even the
end of the game and then it goes into
the final stretch and I'm kind of
getting into spoilers if you haven't
played this game yet so be aware of that
I'm about to keep talking so yeah
spoilers and you get to the tail end of
the thing and there's the mountain a
snowy peak of the mountain and it the
blinding snow and seeing how hard well
not only seeing seeing your characters
pushing against the the wind and like
feeling how hard it is how little like
you're leaning so hard on the analog
stick trying to get him to move further
and he's slowing down and you can feel
how hard it is
humming you just want to get there and
all of this enhanced by the weird kind
of sort of multiplayer because the game
will pair you up with other gamers in
the same section that you're in and
you'll see them and they'll see you you
can't really reasonably interact but you
don't start seeing these things for
about a half hour into the game so it's
just been you in the desert initially
but then like there's somebody else oh
and you can you kind of interact a
little you can you can signal your music
no vacant single there's it's kind of
like a hey over here
Hey look I found this thing that boosts
health or hey I found the way that leads
us to the next bit and you develop a
relation like you you get invested not
only you get invested in your own
faceless uncharacterized avatar you get
invested in your traveling companions
like when I was playing and it's the
very end of the game and you're trudging
through the snow the gut the the the
other player who I was with started to
fall behind and I felt terrible I was I
was too afraid that I would not that my
character would not be able to keep
going if I if I tried to slow down for
this other guy to catch up so I kept
going forward but as I lost sight of him
as in in the blinding snows and I I'm
losing sight and I'm thinking myself
come on just keep go please keep up and
I lose sight of him and I keep going I
felt awful I felt like I'd abandoned
somebody this thing really really
resonate and then the final closing note
is not triumphant its melancholy yet at
the same time it is satisfying this got
as strong an emotional experiences I've
ever gotten out of any 3040 hour plus
game ever in my life
I'm not sure I'm not guessing is it so
past the emotional experience I've ever
had from any other game but it meets it
pretty much any anything else and it is
if you haven't played it I mean yeah I
mean know what you like know what you
come to video games for and if what I
just described sounds to you like it
just sounds boring it may not be for you
and that's fine but if that's not it
intriguing at all and you have not
played this game please I cannot
recommend it enough and seriously it's
two and a half hours it's it's a
theatrical cut of the Lord of the Rings
film a length of time to play through
the whole thing that's that is less time
than most 30 hour video games take
before they stop giving you tutorials I
don't think is a huge time commitment I
think it is well worth it
and I I can't recommend it enough
because it is by a rather heavy margin
the best gaming experience I've had in
the most recent generation of gaming
that I have which is the ps3 generation
it's the best gaming experiences I've
had and I've had other good ones but
that's the peak by a pretty big margin
so that's journey and why I think it's
friggin awesome
so have you played it where are your
thoughts on it
whatever those thoughts might be drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it there's all the stuff to
do you know the like and subscribe
obviously but you can also support me on
patreon you can follow me on Twitter I
have a podcast I have other stuff as
well
links for all of its down in the
description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]